Speaker 1: Let's talk a little
Speaker 2: bit about something
Speaker 1: we've discussed
Speaker 2: quite a bit over
Speaker 1: the last three to four months.
I've been talking to you about the growing
rift within the Republican Party, this sort
of
Speaker 2: civil war, as we're calling it,
Speaker 1: which has mostly been Trump Republicans
versus slightly
Speaker 2: less bonkers
Speaker 1: Republicans.
People like Liz Cheney, Adam Kinzinger, Mitt
Romney
Speaker 2: and some others.
Speaker 1: And I've also said before the Republican
Civil War is good for the left.
Speaker 2: The left should encourage it.
Speaker 1: Let's help along the Republican
Civil War.
Let's weaponize the Republican Civil War against
them to any extent that we can.
We now have a new
Speaker 2: participant in this civil war
Speaker 1: who seems to be trying to play
both sides.
We've not seen this
Speaker 2: before,
Speaker 1: and I'm talking about Republican
Congressman Dan Crenshaw.
Dan Crenshaw, who has put out very confused
takes about socialism and different things.
He seems smart enough to realize that he needs
to figure out a way to play both sides on
this Republican civil war.
Speaker 2: He is actually hugely pro
Speaker 1: Trump on policy, which is hilarious
because it's like what policy?
But OK?
Speaker 2: During the Trump presidency, Crenshaw
Speaker 1: defended Trump's COVID policy.
Totally abortive policy crunch, I defended
it.
Trump said he liked Trump's economic
Speaker 2: policy, Crenshaw
Speaker 1: said he liked Trump's economic
policy, but he's not big on the theatrics.
He's not big on the cartoonish Nadery of the
right, or at least not as big.
Well, Crenshaw spoke at the Texas Liberty
Alliance, and he did something that's very
interesting.
He trashed the cartoonish pro-Trump people
by saying they're grifters.
They didn't actually vote with Trump as much
as I did.
I bring Crenshaw, and it's sort of like treading
water.
So check out this clip and now understand
that when Crenshaw talks about the Freedom
Speaker 2: Caucus, he's talking about Marjorie
Taylor
Speaker 1: Greene, Mo Brooks, Paul Gosar,
Louie Gohmert, Jim
Speaker 2: Jordan.
Speaker 1: Those types of kooky for cocoa
puffs.
Republicans take a look
Speaker 3: supporting these two actually other
veterans and Morgan's race.
There's other frontrunners for why support
these two?
Well, because I've been in Congress for almost
three years now.
There's two types of members in Congress.
There's performance artists, there's legislators
and performance artists are the ones that
get all the attention.
The ones you think are more conservative because
they know how to say slogans real.
Well, you know how to recite the lines that
they know that our voters want to hear.
Let me tell you something.
In the first two years of Trump's presidency,
the Republicans were in control when every
single time they were voting on Donald Trump's
agenda.
What do you think was at the top of that list
voting with Trump and who do you think was
at the bottom?
A lot of names you would recognize were at
the bottom of that list of names you would
recognize are at the top of that list.
Number two is probably going to make you cringe
a little bit.
Adam Kinzinger voted with Trump those 99 percent.
He was number two at the bottom.
Everybody in the Freedom Caucus.
All of them.
What you hear so often is not true.
It's not true.
We have grifters in our midst, not here.
Not like in this room.
And it's not.
I mean, I mean, in the conservative movement,
lie after lie after lie because they know
something psychologically about the conservative
part.
We're worried about what people are going
to do to do to us, what they're going to infringe
upon us.
Speaker 1: So that is super interesting.
First of all, Crenshaw straight up says these
people, Greene and her ilk, these are performance
artists and grifters.
Speaker 2: OK, fair.
Speaker 1: So Crenshaw must be an anti-Trump
Republican, right?
Wrong.
He is criticizing them as grifters because
they perform and they do the theatrics.
But at the end of the day, they are not actually
pro-Trump enough in terms of how they vote.
He says they should be more truly pro-Trump
by actually supporting more of Trump's policies.
Well, Donald Trump was president and then
he says, Hey, you know, who does Adam Kinzinger?
Kinzinger is good.
So then you might say if you've been following
the way the battlelines have been drawn, you
might say, Wow, that's a big attack on the
Trump people, because among Republicans, there
has been no bigger critic of Trump than Adam
Kinzinger, right?
Well, no, not really.
Because Crenshaw is saying Kinzinger is good
because he supports Trump more often than
these Freedom
Speaker 2: Caucus people based on
Speaker 1: voting.
So there's three takeaways here, and they're
all important.
Number one, Crenshaw is smart enough to recognize
the Rift, and he's sort of trying to play
both sides for now because it's unclear what
the future of the Republican Party is in 2022
and 2024.
Is it a Trumpian Republican Party in the coming
election year and in 2024, or is it not?
Speaker 2: So that's one thing
Speaker 1: that he's doing.
Number two, the Civil War is real.
And it should be encouraged because this is
exactly the type of confusion that can create
factions where Republicans damage themselves,
and we should welcome that.
Speaker 2: I mean, to the extent that the
Speaker 1: left is stinking it up.
Let's encourage the right to screw themselves
if we can.
And third, and this is really the key.
And I've told you this before the so-called
anti-Trump Republicans Liz Cheney, Adam Kinzinger,
cetera, they still mostly supported everything
Trump did.
They simply think Joe Biden won in 2020.
Speaker 2: These are not our friends.
Speaker 1: These are still Republican nuts
Speaker 2: who accept the
Speaker 1: election results.
Liz Cheney accepts Trump did something wrong
with Ukraine, but still voted with Trump almost
all the time.
And what's happened is that the bar has been
so lowered that it can be tricky to remember
these are still extremists, right?
If Liz Cheney is basically Dick Cheney politically,
we saw Dick Cheney accurately as a neocon
kook when he was the vice president.
Liz Cheney, more or less under the same Republican
umbrella as Dick Cheney now seems so much
more reasonable because she said Trump lost
the bar is so low that they say one or two
things that are true and we go.
These are good people.
These are not our friends.
These are not our allies.
And let's not get confused and believe that
they are.
We're going to have more on this, and you
can send us your comments on our Instagram.
Speaker 2: Find us at
Speaker 1: David Pakman show on Instagram.
And if you want to see a really wacky hate
mail
Speaker 2: I got yesterday.
Follow me on
Speaker 1: Instagram at David Pakman